I have some hilarious video for you
today from Donald Trump's favorite
television program Fox & Friends in this
video you will see insults of the new
House Intelligence Committee Chairman
Adam Schiff but most interestingly
you're going to hear them say that the
Russia probe is bogus it's nothing like
Benghazi which of course had a dozen
investigations and ultimately found no
wrongdoing other than maybe by
Republicans in the House of
Representatives who refused to provide
additional funding for Diplomatic
Security in the clip I'm about to play
for you you will first hear Brian
Kilmeade then you're going to hear this
former Secret Service guy Dan bond Gino
who is one of the most outrageous
extremists out there right now I saw him
at politican in Los Angeles in October
and this whole cult of personality has
developed around him people were all
over him like sycophants and we're gonna
play the clip it's a minute long and
then there's a whole bunch of stuff I
want to discuss with you about it just
real quick on these what Adam Schiff
said yesterday just - we don't have much
time but he said yesterday he's just
gonna go back into president Trump's
business career to look for anything
that might affect any decisions he make
as president since when this has not
been Ghazi or Whitewater those are
incidents that we they wanted to
investigate they're having just a wide
swath look at a 50 year business career
how was that acceptable well it is it's
it's acceptable to Adam Schiff cuz he's
the sleaziest member of Congress he's a
discredited third-rate conspiracy
theorist who has absolutely zero
credibility and the difference between
the investigations under President Obama
is Ben Ghazi had evidence yeah there
were four body bags
the IRS actually admitted to targeting
citizens the targeting of James Rosen
and others actually happened we have the
legal documents Adam Schiff is inventing
crimes he has no evidence an exclusion
no evidence of financial of nothing he's
making this up because he's sleazy
that's what Adam Schiff does he vows to
investigate as long as it takes the
elections have consequences they would
say so first of all his name is Adam
Schiff not shift
like you're shifting a manual
transmission weird that he doesn't even
know the guys name but he seems to know
so much about all the things that are
bad about him so first of all they say
this is nothing like Benghazi I actually
agree with them we have dozens of
indictments here endless criminality has
actually been found
unlike Benghazi then bond Geno calls
ship or as he calls him shift a
conspiracy theorist and mentions the IRS
scandal
remember the scandal they're referring
to is the supposed targeting of
conservative nonprofits by the IRS which
was investigated and what we found out
was that there was almost no targeting
whatsoever it was not a widespread
scandal the way it was described but
instances were found of progressive and
left-wing nonprofits being targeted not
conservative ones so that's bogus and
then we get to sort of the rubber
meeting the road on this which is that
the Trump Russia probe is different in
that it's not a complete waste of time
Republicans did one two year
investigation into Benghazi and what
they found was that everybody acted
appropriately other than maybe the
republican-controlled House of
Representatives which didn't authorize
more money that was needed for
diplomatic security at the request of
then Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
then more investigations followed a
dozen in total and unlike Benghazi the
Russia probe has both probable cause and
purpose even the first Benghazi invest
investigation we could say Pat didn't
have it wrong in the sense that it made
sense to investigate that four people
died
Hillary showed up testified for hours
something Trump won't do and everybody
was cleared that's the main difference
well Dan bond Geno to his credit he is
being loud and angry so therefore he
must be right and of course he's
repeating the tired talking point that
there's no evidence of Trump Russia
collusion that ignores the Trump Tower
meeting and the plans to build a tower
in Moscow and the WikiLeaks exchanges
and the countless indictments and guilty
pleas that we have adding up now so I
wonder if they're just arguing in bad
faith at this point if they're just
ignoring all that stuff and they can
to say that it's just not true there is
evidence well everything that's
happening on fox news seems to be
coordinated with Trump I mean the fact
that the even last night the timing of
Trump's rally in El Paso and how it
interacted with the timing of when Sean
Hannity goes on Fox News it's abundantly
clear that there is a lot of
conversation we know Trump watches this
show we know Hannity is giving Trump
advice and they're talking late at night
before Trump's Trump goes to bed it's
abundantly clear that they are all but
officially state media at this point and
it wouldn't surprise me if they are
parroting talking points that they know
to be false simply to appease the
President of the United States